christmas is exactly one week away and
while holiday travel is on the minds of
many the omicron variant is causing some
cancellations madison kimbrough is at
harry reid international airport with
more on what people are saying along
with tips for traveling this season
madison
the holidays can always be a stressful
time and now with this new variant
people are on extra high alert
here at harry reid international all the
safety protocols are still the same but
if you're flying in the next coming week
pay close attention to your flight as
there's a possibility it may get delayed
or canceled just this past week there
have been so many delays and
cancellations within the sports world
along with entertainment here in vegas
there haven't been any reports of
cancellations due to the new variant but
time will tell we caught up with some
travelers who shared whether or not the
omicron variant has affected their
holiday plans thus far i'm really not
concerned about it at all we didn't feel
that anything would get canceled here
but that's a good question i know this
is a real thing and people need to take
it seriously for me traveling was good
because i've gotten the two vaccines and
the booster so i keep my mask on when
necessary as for making your traveling
experience as easy as possible the
obvious check in ahead of time arrive
early and wear your mask some tips for
holiday travel if you bring wrapped
gifts make sure they won't set off
security if you think it will it's
probably best to leave it unwrapped
while flying
as of now the airport is very busy but
we're not seeing any delays or
cancellations just yet that might change
though as we get closer to christmas
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now